Does "The Way of Water" circle
down a plothole-sized drain in
its final act? Or are some fans
missing the ocean for the waves?
After keeping fans waiting for 13 years, James
Cameron's "Avatar: The Way of Water" has arrived
in theaters. The film sees Jake Sully and his
family leaving the sanctity of their forest home
to live with an ocean tribe of Na'vi people in
order to escape a vengeful Colonel Miles Quaritch.
The sequel began development shortly after the
monumental 2009 release of the first "Avatar."
Following a series of delays, the film is finally
out for the world to see in all its 3D glory.
"Let's get it done."
While the first "Avatar" has never been seen as a
groundbreaking feat of storytelling, the visuals
and worldbuilding introduced in it have been more
than enough to satisfy moviegoers. This appears
to be the case for its sequel as well, with its
Rotten Tomatoes consensus calling it "a stunningly
immersive experience." But it seems that even
the most jaw-dropping visuals on earth can do
little to hide a notable plot hole regarding the
film's final act that fans simply cannot ignore.
The third act of "The Way of Water" centers on
a grand battle between the Na'vi and Colonel
Quaritch's gang. But for those who think that the
newly-introduced Metkayina Na'vi ocean tribe would
be by Jake Sully's side, think again. On a Reddit
thread discussing the film, one user points out,
They go on to describe how the Metkayina
disappear following their fight to protect
the whale-like Tulkuns, leaving Sully and his
family to go against Quaritch's gang alone.
"I need you with me."
Other fans chimed in, coming up
with their own justifications for
the absence of the Metkayina
during the fight. Many saw it
as the Metkayina people looking out for
themselves, like this user, who posted,
Another Redditor agreed, writing,
However, another user offered a solid rebuttal,
seeing the storytelling purpose for this, posting,
"Honestly, I think it was an intended plot
hole because Cameron wanted to focus on the
family unit ... All of that would have
been [moot] had the sea tribe stayed."
While the Metkayina could have had a more active
hand in the final act of "Avatar: The Way of
Water," this is far from a reflection of their
involvement throughout the rest of the franchise.
With the end of "Way of Water" confirming that
the Metkayina will be helping Jake Sully in his
ongoing battle against humanity and director James
Cameron confirming that "Avatar 3" will be coming
out, it seems that we've only touched the surface
of what the water-bound tribe has to offer.
Kate Winslet, who portrays the Metkayina
chief's wife Ronal in "Way of Water,"
says that her character, in particular, is a
crucial piece of the puzzle in the future of
the "Avatar" universe. In an interview
with Variety, the "Titanic" star said,
James Cameron and pulse-pounding finales are a
match made in heaven, so hopefully, whatever the
Metkayina tribe have up their slippery sleeves
will make up for any plot hole complaints.